[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
tuesday we're back again
talking about another movie
i've been wanting to do this one for a
really long time and the thing about it
was that i wanted tom to like watch it
with me because i said oh you probably
like really dig this movie but he was
like in and out of the room like doing
something else so i think you saw some
of it but you didn't really see most of
it you know
yeah i saw it
[Laughter]
you didn't see like most of the first
part though
but this is like a good flick it's a
good flick and i kind of feel like maybe
um
i don't know i don't i kind of feel like
a lot of people don't really talk about
it that much anymore even though it was
like a pretty big hit at the time i
actually remember
oh [ __ ] there you go
coming in
i actually remember seeing this when it
uh came out in the theater back in 2009
so the thing about this movie is that
what had happened because you know sam
raimi was really you know
obviously like known for evil dead and
[ __ ] like that
but he wrote the story
that would eventually become drag me to
hell which was i think was originally
called the curse him and his brother
ivan wrote it
like 10 years prior so i think it was
like 1999
and then he got all swept up in making
the spider-man movies
and so he never could like get around to
it so when this came out i kind of feel
like this was seen as like his
triumphant return to horror that was
something more along the lines of evil
dead even though this is rated pg-13
which is crazy because when i was
re-watching it
he got away with a lot for pg-13 i mean
he basically said he's like well i
didn't want to make it like super gory
or like over the top and stuff like that
like the evil dead movies were
but
he still got i mean this is a pretty
gross
movie but not gross in the sense of like
bloody
it's gross in the sense of
other fluids you know what i mean
like i don't know just like [ __ ]
gross flies and like people like
throwing up on people and [ __ ] like that
so he got away with a lot for uh
for such a for a pg-13 rating which you
try to do but
i had seen this movie like i said i saw
the theater
when it came out and then i saw it a
couple times after that
um but i forgot how [ __ ] fun this
movie was what are you doing i forgot i
got to move the car
oh god look at those groceries oh that's
right he left my car like in front of
the
in front of the thing so yeah he's real
prepared for all this stuff
ah but yeah anyway um where was i yeah
so i forgot like uh what a good time
this movie was how funny it was i mean i
don't know i guess i should have like
remembered but
um yeah so
okay so if you haven't seen drag me to
hell i also like too that the
the movie like uh
really goes for the bleak ass ending
although i think the big i was watching
like a couple other reviews about this
earlier
but
it's debatable over whether i mean i'm
going to spoil the ending because this
movie's been out a long time and i kind
of feel like even if you haven't seen it
you probably know what happens at the
end
but you could like definitely make
an argument that the main character
didn't really deserve what happened to
her but to me i kind of think that's
what makes the movie
more fun i guess or like more ballsy
even though the end is just kind of like
holy [ __ ] they actually like went there
because i thought she was gonna
wangle out of it somehow but yeah no she
didn't sam raimi also directed says
slasher fred some no no horror movies
like oz the great and powerful and for
the love of the game he did uh a simple
plan too which i guess was not but that
was more a thriller i gotta i just
bought that book not too long ago which
was scott smith the same guy that wrote
the ruins
and i've seen the movie like a long time
ago but i don't think i've ever read the
book and i've heard the book is like
excellent so i've been wanting to read
it so i bought it but i haven't read it
yet and he did the gift too which i
guess was still kind of a horror movie
but it was more like a
like a psychic uh
murder mystery type thing that i
remember i think i saw that in the
theater too that i'm thinking about it
and actually i've been wanting to
rewatch that one too because i think um
i don't know it's on one of the
streaming services this is actually on
hulu and that's where i watch it so the
gift might be on hulu as well
granthar says true story sam raimi once
gave granthar a fifth of crown royal ooh
nice granthar worked at a summer camp in
ontario canada where sam had been a
camper he returned at the end of one
summer to hang out that's pretty cool
super down to earth guy he is he always
struck me as a is a pretty cool dude and
i really like i think a lot of people
were excited when this movie came out
because
you know it would almost be like peter
jackson like after he made the lord of
the rings movies going back and doing
something like dead alive again you know
what i mean so i just thought that was
like really cool and like i said it was
like super fun so if you've never seen
this movie what happens in this movie
is that there's a young woman who's
played by allison loman
and her name is christine
and she's a loan officer and she's kind
of gunning for this assistant manager
position but there's this other [ __ ]
in her office named stu [ __ ] stew
and he's kind of
he's he hasn't been there that long but
he's a real ass kisser and he's real
like condescending toward her and [ __ ]
like that like the
the stuff that happens like early on
where he's just kind of like she's like
hey i'm gonna take my lunch break hey
why don't you pick me up a sandwich like
bubble like that kind of stuff i'd be
like go get your own sandwich chode but
yeah so there's that kind of thing
so she's got him for that position but
she's not really sure if she's gonna get
it because her boss is like well you
know we need somebody that's gonna be
able to like make the tough decisions
and all this other kind of stuff she's
also got this boyfriend played by justin
long who you probably recognize from
tusk and many other movies but he's like
he's kind of wealthy it seems like i
think he's like some kind of doctor and
he had a doctor a psychiatrist or he
just came out of medical school or
something and his parents are like super
super snotty and they're kind of like
well we don't think she's just like a
farm girl so she's like not good enough
for you and blah blah so she's kind of
under a lot of pressure like to do well
at work and
kind of get her [ __ ] together there's
also this kind of underlying thing that
she used to be a fat girl and so she's
kind of like trying to be this whole new
person
so it so happens that right after the
boss says we need somebody who's gonna
make the tough decisions
this creepy old woman comes into the
bank named sylvia ganoush
and she needs another
loan extension because she hasn't been
able to pay her mortgage for the past
couple months now the bank has already
extended her
to uh you know had to have given her two
extensions and she wants a third one but
she just needs a little bit longer to
like come up with the money and
everything like that
and christine is initially
sympathetic
even though even though the old woman's
pretty gross i mean you know what i mean
she's she's like hocking up loogies into
like a into her [ __ ] handkerchief and
like she steals all her candy like off
her desk when she's not looking and [ __ ]
like that like she's pretty gross but
she figures well you know i'm gonna like
put my foot down and say no we
absolutely can't do it so then the old
woman gets like really mad and she's
kind of like then she well she actually
like begs she like gets it down her
knees and starts begging and everything
and then uh christine like flips out and
calls security and everything so then
the woman basically
is like you shamed me and she's like oh
[ __ ] you're in trouble now and later on
there's a great scene where christine is
like leaving the bank and she's going
into the
into the uh parking garage
and
the the woman like uh mrs ganoush is
like in there and they have this huge
like [ __ ] fight like in and around
the car it's so sam raimi and it's like
so awesome and it's like the [ __ ] the
old ladies like dentures like pop out
and then she's like gumming another the
girl on the face and [ __ ] like that it's
like so [ __ ] gross but i mean the
thing about it i don't know if you could
get away with because it's essential
it's a gypsy curse is what it is um and
you know it does seem like
it doesn't really paint uh gypsies or
the roma in a very flattering light you
know what i mean um but
there is like you are kind of like
sympathetic toward this woman and you're
not necessarily you're kind of
sympathetic toward christine because
you know it's
yeah she could have given the woman the
loan extension but it's like she'd
already asked for two and she's like
she's trying to get a job and [ __ ] like
that but as the movie goes on
i don't know it's like christine is like
a good person
but
she makes some sort of like questionable
decisions later on so you could actually
argue
because as i said spoiler alert the name
of the movie is drag me to hell she
absolutely does get dragged to hell at
the end um she doesn't get out of the
curse at all like she tries to get
around it but there's various things
that um that kind of conspire to keep
that from happening
but the thing about it is that she could
have
well okay
it didn't work out this way but she
could have like given the curse away to
somebody but she couldn't bring herself
to do it however
she did sacrifice her kitten
thinking that that would make the demon
which is called the lamia would make the
demon go away
it didn't so she killed the cat for
nothing so
in that way i was kind of like man maybe
she does suck maybe
[Laughter]
don't [ __ ] with the cats don't [ __ ] with
the cats well the thing about it is like
even if i mean like i said it didn't end
up working out because what happens is
like
the woman curses her and then they're
like okay well the lamia the demon is
gonna like torment you for three days
and then it's gonna drag you to hell so
that's pretty much how it's gonna go so
she starts seeing like shadows and like
she has like poltergeist activity like
[ __ ] shit's throwing her around the
apartment and all this other kind of
stuff so all this crazy [ __ ] is
happening like the old like the ghost of
the old woman like shows up and pukes on
her and it's like oh there's all kind of
disgusting [ __ ] happening like so many
fluids
um
so she ends up going to like a psychic
and the psychic is like yeah you have a
curse on you well he's like i don't
really know much about this is a little
bit above my pay grade but it's like
maybe if you sacrificed an animal to the
demon like maybe that will be what at
which point even if that had helped
i mean why wouldn't you just why would
you sacrifice your little kitty why
wouldn't you just go and get like go
somewhere and get like a chicken or
something or a turkey that you were
gonna eat and just say yeah i'm gonna
sacrifice that like don't sacrifice your
cat for christ's sake that's like [ __ ]
up and it didn't even end up working
anyway and then the thing about it too
is that toward the end
where uh where the psychic says well i
didn't really want to tell you this
earlier because then you're essentially
just passing the curse on to somebody
else um if you
give the thing that the woman cursed
which in her case is like a button like
off her coat if you give that to
somebody else then the demon will come
get them
at which point i was just like why don't
you just give the button to stew because
he's a [ __ ] taint so
you know he was like trying to steal her
job and was like i don't know he was
just kind of a dick i was like like i
said nobody in this movie like deserves
like eternal torment and hell and stuff
but he was like the shittiest person in
the movie so i would have just given him
the button and i wouldn't even felt all
that bad about it but she couldn't do it
she just like she felt really good about
it how long ago was it we watched this
movie
two nights ago two nights ago i think
okay i think it was two nights ago yeah
for some reason it didn't really make a
big impression on me well you hardly
watched you hardly saw bits of it you
hardly thought it seemed kind of samey
and i don't remember what i was doing at
the time no it's super fun you should've
like sat and watched it it's like really
funny like i said it's almost kind of
like it's not as
quite as crazy as evil dead but it had
like the same spirit as evil dead like
that same kind of like funny like a
little bit of zayn
without me i must have been cooking
no well i was wait i don't know what you
were doing you were just like wandering
around and i thought like it was getting
late so i was just like well [ __ ] i just
gotta i gotta watch it so
and then i thought you were gonna come
back in but you never did i was just
like yeah yeah no it's good it's good
like it had like
well like i said it's hard to like judge
how good a movie is if you're not like
watching it if you're not like paying
attention because like you don't really
know she's teaching me how to watch a
movie no it's like well you don't really
know what's going on and it's like you
haven't really followed it you just come
in and you're just like you have no idea
what's going on he started it without me
well i thought you were coming in the
room and then you just kept
[Music]
i got all kinds of [ __ ] i go out there
and move the [ __ ] card and i forgot
the sprinklers were on the sprinklers
turned on while i was out there and got
me
got all this automatic [ __ ] happening
well that's what happens
having a [ __ ] weed eating crab did
all kind we had to do a supply run today
went to walmart
gotta hate walmart bomb i said yeah
walmart was pretty rough
but it was it was well stocked though
well i mean i couldn't go i have too
much i have [ __ ] to do it's like i asked
you to go i don't want to go one i hate
i hate walmart and see i hate going
walmart okay and two i had like a whole
bunch of graphic design jobs i had to do
yeah all right sit back here and make
money that's what i'm saying it's like i
can't just like go to [ __ ] walmart i
hate walmart
grantham says whatever happened to
allison lohman she was great in
matchstick men too yeah she was actually
but she hasn't been in much recently i
don't really know what happened to her
and honestly she's great in this
and the thing about it is that
when she read the script for this
uh she must have been like oh my god i'm
gonna have like every possible like
bodily fluid like all everybody like
it's gonna be like so disgusting
and she went ahead and did it anyway and
i was like man good for her because
there's like some scenes where
you know the old lady is like
you know when her teeth pop out and
she's like gumming her face like this
and it's just kind of like now some of
the [ __ ] is cgi
which is one that's kind of the only um
that's like the only negative that i
have about it is that
some of the cgi
didn't really age very well you know
what i'm saying it usually doesn't well
yeah that's what i'm saying and so i
kind of wish they had done more
practical effects like it's okay because
it's mostly like a fantasy it's about a
gypsy curse for christ's sake um
but
like the last scene where she actually
gets dragged into hell and like her face
goes all [ __ ] up that's like a little
bit but that's you know it's it's goofy
looking but that's kind of like this is
almost kind of like i don't want to say
it's almost like a live action cartoon
because it's not that
it's not as crazy as evil dead like i
said but
it has that same spirit to it even
though it's a little bit more grounded
in reality but yeah allison lowman was
great in this um the woman that played
sylvia ganoush was great in this she was
like
super gross
but still kind of like sympathetic like
you could you know you could understand
like why she was bad and [ __ ] you know
what it's funny this should be a double
feature with stephen king's thinner
because they're both about a gypsy curse
i haven't seen the thinner in a long
time well i've been wanting to watch it
i think i put it in the i remember
liking it yeah it's it's not bad we saw
a dark half about what a year and a half
ago something like that and i liked it
yeah it's kind of like um
you know you know it was funny what's
that the [ __ ] bad guy from dark calf
yes from jones county yeah mississippi
yeah that's right that's where my
family's from it's either joan or jasper
they're right next to each other yeah
but it was on his car it's on his
license plate
you know but there aren't any bad asses
like that
like that [ __ ]
running around in a suit with cowboy hat
and guns and [ __ ] [ __ ] raping people
you get caught pretty quick doing what
he was doing there in charlottesville
jones county isn't that bad isn't that
big everybody knows each other
[Laughter]
well the thing like i said um thinner i
think is also on hulu because this is on
hulu and i think thinner has been on
horizon on because i put it in the poll
like a couple times but it didn't win
and i was just like well we've been
doing like a lot of stephen king
adaptations like yesterday we didn't
evil things and like we did the fire
starter ones and stuff like that so
maybe we should do center as well
because i wouldn't mind i remember it
being pretty good yeah i remember as as
far as it's a it's a little bit cheesy
but a lot of the ones from that era were
because that's like 90s i remember the
book a lot more than the movie and i
let's see if the movie stacks up to the
book
whether the damn mafia hitman shows up
with an ak-47 and all that
i don't remember that actually happened
i think it does but i can't remember
it's been a long time since i've seen it
you had a friend who was in a mafia
who's hit man yeah yeah yeah shows up
with an ak-47 well he's in the movie i
remember he's in a movie i just don't
remember couples up some car with it and
everything yeah [ __ ] like that right
um let me see do do do do do
uh james knapp says hi jenny wanna ask a
sidetrack did tom watch uh stonehurst
asylum movie was a great review and
recommendation no i watched that but i
watched that but um speaking of what i
gotta go ahead and [ __ ]
oh this is from we just got this today
this is from
our friend louis hernandez he's of
course always sending good movies
friends to the sheriff godfather the
godfather trilogy celebrating the 50th
anniversary that's really right on that
[ __ ] so thanks very much louis yes he's
requesting that's awesome he's
requesting a review we'll do we should
do these yeah we'll do so we'll do the
three godfather movies like for the next
matinee
like we'll do that like sunday monday
tuesday did we do collateral we did
collateral right yes okay yeah yeah we
did yeah it turned out it was a good
movie
it was tom cruise as an
slash
assassin
friend said thinner was directed by tom
holland that's right i had forgotten
about that uh not the actor that was in
the spider-man movie okay um a gypsy
cursed john holmes by saying longer and
thicker to him
[Laughter]
yeah i like that i kind of wish some
gypsy would curse me and say thinner
that'd be nice um well i mean not until
i starve to death but you know
zack says for some reason
uh a detail i like in this is where the
lady is tapping her fingers on the desk
and the first thing that chick does is
look at her stapler then sees the hand
yeah i really like i mean i really like
all the framing of the shots in this
it's like really really good but my
favorite sequence i think
my favorite sequence is where they have
that big fight in the car you know what
i mean and like they're smacking each
other around in the car and like [ __ ]
christine is like [ __ ] stapling she
staples her in the head and she's like
she's got a stapler with her that and
like the sean scene at the end where
they're trying to like put the demon
into the goat and then the goat talks
and [ __ ] like that it's like that's
[ __ ] crazy it's real i don't know i
really like this movie um
yeah it's one that
um i kind of feel like it
i think it only cost like 30 million to
make only 30 million and it made like 90
91 million so it was actually pretty
successful and like i said i remember a
lot of people talking about it at the
time because i saw in the theater but it
was one that
people like really seemed to have a lot
of fun with when it came out but then
like it
didn't you don't really hear people
talking about it that much anymore
but i don't know
i've been wanting to rewatch sam raimi's
other movie the gift as well because i
remember liking that one a lot i think i
saw that one also in the theater i think
cate blanchett is in that
and like i said that's more like a
thriller murder mystery type thing so
it's not like as crazy as this one but
this one's just like a lot of fun it's
just fun and it's funny and it's gross
and i don't know i just really really
like this one so
i don't know and i thought you would
like it but like i said you didn't
really watch you didn't really sit and
watch it you were kind of like just
wandering around so you weren't really
she was getting on me oh you were paying
attention i wasn't paying attention no i
wasn't doing my job
says jenny have you ever done the
adventures of buckaroo bonsai across the
eighth dimension no but that's another
one that i do want to do because i saw
that on cable like lots of times back in
the old days you never saw it and
it might be on amazon prime i think i
saw it when i was scrolling through one
of the streaming services the other day
and we mentioned it yesterday because
when we were talking about
needful things the guy that wrote the
screenplay for needful things i think
also
directed buckaroo bonsai or i think he
directed buckaroo banzai so
it kind of reminded me of it so we'll
get around to it uh probably khan also
wanted me to talk about northman because
he just saw him him and his son just saw
the norman oh yeah you guys just say it
yeah he liked it he thought he wanted
more so it kind of he didn't think it
was as good as conan wanted it it left
him one and i didn't but then he said
well it's different and i said yeah
so he's trying to get me to talk about
it right now but dude i already reviewed
that movie go back and watch the video
now you've seen it you'll [ __ ]
understand what i said about it earlier
it's it's good it's good movie
i can't wait to own it
but yeah like i said
conan one which is an epic [ __ ] tale
all right uh amelia's and [ __ ] stone
worked on that [ __ ] okay
uh had a lot of good philosophy a lot of
story a lot of lessons behind it in in
certain edits like i want to get a
complete edit
i got to edit but i got a good
edit but it's missing one scene that's
in some of the other ones about
springtime which explains the damn
the eye of the serpent
metaphor
but like i was saying conan one is like
if this is heavy metal
that's classic iron maiden
all right
again the northman is more kind of like
cradle of filth or [ __ ]
celtic frost or
venom or something it's [ __ ] harder
harder
but there's still mythicism there you
know there's a lot of myth and a lot of
good storytelling and it's
pretty legit in terms of accuracy
in terms of the scale and what they did
it is a good movie it'll stand the test
of time
it'll be around for a long time i think
it was real well made even though it's
funny is that that director is not known
for those kind of movies
but he did a [ __ ] good job
it's a masterpiece
well you've never you've never seen the
witch have you oh he did that one too
huh yeah
okay
because i've heard that i heard that
he's actually kind of soy he's kind of
like you know
but maybe it's not true maybe it's just
a rumor
they said that that that [ __ ]
whatever yeah he said that that movie is
evidently kind of like [ __ ]
uncharacter uncharacteristically savage
for him
not true
well i don't know he's only made three
movies dude okay
it's just and the only one you haven't
seen because we both saw the lighthouse
you haven't seen you didn't see the
witch the lighthouse was good yeah i
liked the light it was weird
yeah i like that's what i liked about it
a little weird
more people need to make weird moves
this movie was [ __ ] weird
i'm not even sure what the ending meant
i was just when i saw it i was like okay
all right you got me yeah hugo said the
witch is good it is the witch is great
good i love that movie we'll see
uh kanavasan says i was re-watching your
flash gordon review yesterday yeah yeah
that was one of the first ones that we
did i think yeah i bet you the audio's
terrible on that
i'm sure it's not that bad i went back
and listened to one of our old shows and
it's like you're talking through a damn
metal too
the [ __ ] microphone we had back then
we weren't you know we were a new show
there's some of them that i need to redo
i want to redo conan i wouldn't mind
redoing um
um flash gordon
because there's a lot in flash
coordinates miss that that you know
there's a lot to that one
yeah i mean if you want to go back and
like redo some of the old ones that we
did we could do that i mean yes we need
to do some redos i wouldn't mind redoing
we said we were going to redo all of the
omega man variants
which is all that i am legend yeah all
the i am legend of mega man we're gonna
do this i wouldn't mind doing like
redoing some stuff like um some of the
early ones we did like legend of
hellhouse and stuff like that
yeah because i really like that stuff
that had inferior audio quality or maybe
we weren't really on point on the show
you know just anything needs to be
redone
conan needs to be redone
zach says i just realized as of this
spring i'll have been watching you guys
for four years it's ridiculous wow that
is that's ridiculous it's ridiculous how
long we've been yeah tammy said redo the
shining
we should yeah well we did a show like
kind of about the shining and then
i think we did it was that was show one
wasn't it
yeah
the shot well it was the shining and the
entity yeah um and i want to redo that
entity case too like not just the movie
but i want to talk about the case so i
put that in the poll i think it was
either it's either in this poll or it's
gonna be the next week one but um what
was that what else was i gonna say
oh and we also did remember when we went
to the theater
and we saw
the shining like on the big screen like
you know fathom events did it and i
think we talked about it a little bit
then but
i don't know there's just like so
there's so much about it i never get
sick of talking about that movie because
there's just always something because
that channel collated learning he's got
like [ __ ] tons of
hours and hours and hours and hours of
stuff about the shining yeah some of it
a little i think he's going a little out
there sometimes some of it is but
you know 2001
space odyssey is is wrong a lot
i didn't i haven't seen that one yeah
because i guess he didn't read the book
and he doesn't know what happened in
2010 uh which is like the sequel
there's a lot of
or maybe you know maybe he has but he's
just trying to show he's just trying to
talk about what kubrick was trying to
say
you know in that particular shot that
that the monolith is actually the the
movie screen and then there's like a
meta thing i don't think that's what it
was
oh you know correlative learning came
out with a brand new one about uh the
black hole the disney movie the black
hole yeah and it's good it's kind of
like what the [ __ ] but i saw but he saw
even more with like uh
hidden in the architecture the uh
all-seeing eye like on the back of the
dollar bills like an a-frame a-frames
over and over against with us with a
star and i in the middle and trying to
draw a pair of those well you i'll watch
it you'll like it there is some deeper
meanings to the black hole
oscar said you guys should do the ninth
configuration we already did we did it
we did the ninth configuration yeah i
don't know it was a while back yeah i
don't remember it there was a lot of
movies like the ninth configuration that
was a weird fight that was a weird
[ __ ] movie yeah
which one was that there was a lot of
angel heart we did that one hard we did
that one too we did that one too that
was a good one we did angel heart too
um did serpent a rainbow we did all
those
yeah we def we definitely did do uh
granthar says please redo chariots of
fire i don't think we should we didn't
do chariots of fire in the first place
we
didn't [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
uh
as i like collate of learning says zach
but i think he gives kubrick way too
much credit guy was smart but no one has
that much attention yeah yeah i mean
some of this stuff i enjoy like watching
i mostly i watch because he does ones i
watch the ones about the shining and i
think he does ones about david lynch
movies so i usually watch those as well
because i'm really into that um
but yeah sometimes i like watching them
but sometimes yeah some of it's like a
little bit too out there it's a little
bit of a reach but
that's okay that's okay uh zak says also
still waiting for you guys to do cluet
yeah we still need to do that i'm sorry
we haven't got around to it yet
we've got like
we've got so many [ __ ] movies we
gotta do yeah but yeah and like i said
if somebody sends us movies
and hard copies
um
these get moved to the front of line
for reviews especially if they're
[ __ ] blu-rays all right [ __ ]
um
hernandez is [ __ ] he's got a [ __ ]
killer reputation for sending he knows
my tastes all right he'll send me some
badass clicks that i've never seen
before yeah he always sends good stuff
like and even if it's stuff that we've
never seen before they're always like
really you know
i guess we got a similar taste in the
movie
he sent me that [ __ ] um pain and gain
movie that [ __ ] that blew me away and
then after that [ __ ] he just started
sending good movies
got to see panty gain again startup 78
says do barry lyndon yeah we should
because i
i've only seen that one time this is
stanley kubrick movie and i've saw it
like when i was a teenager i think
so it was like a long time ago that i
saw it
so i definitely think that's worth a
re-watch tammy says with all that we
want you to review and you going to redo
old shows this show will never end
probably well that's the idea and that's
it well in a way that's kind of why i
started doing my own movie and book
reviews and [ __ ] like that because i
said i'm just it's like i like a lot of
new horror movies and like a lot of ones
like tom doesn't give a [ __ ] about
watching them so i said well i'm just
gonna do them on my own because i'm
getting behind i can't watch that many
horror movies so just that genre it's
i mean it's got to be something real
special which some of them are but a lot
of them are just kind of saying me to me
well i usually try to pick ones that are
that have like a lot of buzz about them
so at least there's something that's
like a lot of people are talking about
because if i just like picked movies at
random most of them would just be like
meh you know what i mean so i usually
try to pick something that like a lot of
people are talking about did we do
mid-summer
yes did we do fighting with my family
we did a matinee on it because we saw it
in the theater i think we need to do a
review of one of these days to fight
with my family i love that movie and
that's a florida movie yeah
yeah it's a good movie i've watched it
here twice since i bought it
and it's rewashable and there's an
extended cut on the blu-ray did you know
that
yeah it's got some extra scenes and
stuff it's good do eyes wide shut we did
that one too did it we did it we did
that good movie
some people say kubrick's weakest but i
don't think so relevant to today he's
talking about that man with that island
with all them children on it it's not my
favorite of his but it's still pretty
good one of the things i like about that
movie is that tom cruise is a isn't is
kind of like a bad guy in it he's not a
good guy in it yeah he's kind of a jerk
it's kind of a dirt kind of a dick yeah
he's kind of a flawed character with
[ __ ] jealousies that he [ __ ] and
[ __ ] you know i mean but but he's what
he was fooling around his wife anyway
sort of sort of i mean for one too yeah
um but then he had like the audacity to
like she just like
she fantasized about something and
didn't even do anything
and then he gets all [ __ ] upset about
it well kubrick called it yeah he called
it that's that's not there's guys like
that yeah i know they're like you're
trying to [ __ ] get the ass and she
just thinks about the dick and you want
to [ __ ] that's the that's the weapons
grade projection right there man that's
some projection
he's projecting yeah you got to get over
that kind of [ __ ] that's
what that is once you're once you reach
a certain age that shouldn't affect you
that much it's all just passing [ __ ]
anyway you know [ __ ] you women gonna
think what they think
it's all right it's just part of being
human i mean you know you probably don't
want to know most of what i think i
don't even wanna know talking about
talking
[Laughter]
it may shock you to know that a lot of
things i think are not about you
i'm thinking about anyway yeah
i know you like to think you're like the
center of the universe that is not true
yeah yeah it is i was trying to think of
what else gramster says spring breakers
the florida project and charlie wilson's
war will send as soon as possible yes
those those would all be excellent blair
to dude says movie children shouldn't
play with dead things you know what i
saw that movie first because that came
out what 1972 like same year i was born
i saw that movie when i was
way too young to be seeing it
and that scared the crap out of me and i
always remember like it's scaring the
crap out of me and then like i decided i
was going to watch it again like a few
years ago and i'm like that is like the
shittiest yeah i don't remember that
i remember that although i do kind of
want to rewatch it though because i was
like
it's it's so so cheap the one that i
remembered as a kid that remember really
creeping me out and then seeing again
goes oh no that was a good movie it was
alice sweet alice
yeah we reviewed that one too yeah
that's a good ass movie a good movie
it's like a jello yeah kind of right
it's like an american jesus crazy ass
[ __ ]
chick she's probably about what 13 or 14
yeah [ __ ] weird [ __ ] that she [ __ ]
does yes i love that movie that's like
one of my favorite um 70s horror movies
for sure i thought it was italian but it
wasn't as american wouldn't it yeah it's
a fake italian movie yeah well like i
said it's like well they had american
jello movies too that were like that
style don't look now was kind of like a
it was kind of like a giallo movie it
had well it had some of the same like
tropes as a jello movie by the way um
on my flickers of fear series i think
july i'm going to do all
giallo movies like for the month of july
because i've got them all like on the
calendar and there's a couple of new
ones because i think one of you guys
recommended one called disco path which
is like a newer movie i think it's 2014
2015 which is like a giallo slasher but
like a guy that hears disco music and it
makes them want to kill people
so and it's on to be so it's like okay
well i want to do that one and then
there's like a new newish giallo called
francesca
which i want to do as well because i've
done a couple we've done a couple of
like newer jll movies like the editor
which is
amazing if you haven't seen if you like
giala movies see the editor i think it
came out in 2014 2015 something like
that it's on shutter or it was um and
it's [ __ ] hilarious oscar said
lighthouse sucked
i don't know why you're on his channel
[ __ ] i loved later i don't know why
you're on his channel oscar [ __ ] i
don't get it that movie was good zach
said i'd love to see you do fatal
attraction yeah we should do the fatal
attraction i was i like that a long time
i've seen that i saw that in the theater
i think
lighthouse was good but it was good in
the theater because it was so [ __ ]
weird
so [ __ ] weird it was good though
and i don't know what it meant it meant
something at the end when he looks into
the lighthouse and goes ah they were
drinking the lighthouse [ __ ] oil yeah
hugo says adventures of baron munchausen
that would be another good one to do oh
another one speaking of that that just
reminded me of i'd really like to do
time bandits i can't believe we have a
whole one yeah man i love [ __ ] time
bandits i saw it like a million times
when i was uh when i was growing up you
were watching jabberwock you remember
that yeah yeah we just re-watched
jabberwocky it was weird i don't think
did we get through it yeah i think we
did yeah yeah i like jabberwocky's good
but i like time bandits way better i
mean time bandits is awesome i love that
[ __ ] movie like i love [ __ ] um
david warner is in it
like as the [ __ ] evil
overlord of the universe or whatever the
hell oh my god it's so funny
uh straight up 78 is there a p.o box we
can send blu-rays to no which i mean you
could just set it to her like a home
address but i'm not going to say the
home address on the yeah in public just
like send me a message
and i'll give you like our homework
you're asking us because we don't um
straw dog say oh yeah okay yeah even
it's not some rando it's okay
he's like yeah just make sure tell me
where you live just make sure we don't
already have it
uh yeah oh it says uh i was thinking of
sending true detective season three oh
okay okay yeah we don't have it yeah we
don't have that what is we only have
season do we only have something one on
seven only have season one i think we
only have season one yeah yeah i don't
think we have season three i mean we'll
check
uh uh yeah khan says i did not get the
lighthouse dude
let me with your analysis
i have to go back and see it again i
knew it was some kind of uh some kind of
allegory
it was an allegory for something else
but i don't know what it was that's
something that's like a lynch flick you
have to go back and [ __ ] see
watch it again it meant something
yeah i mean you know i like movies you
have to go back and like watch a couple
of times two guys on an island and the
lighthouse meant something they had to
keep it burning and they started turning
on each other
and
it was kind of like a love-hate
relationship
and then uh
they went insane they were drinking the
[ __ ] lighthouse fluid that movie was
[ __ ] hilarious but yeah a lot of
hilarious [ __ ] happens
dancing with each other and [ __ ]
snapping each other around and
spy out on each other jerking off and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] weird [ __ ]
worst roommate ever yeah fourth throw
down says jagged edge that's another one
that i've been wanting to do i think i
might have put that one in one of the
patreon polls but i don't think it won i
because i remember i don't know was it
what i do when i do the patreon polls is
i'll go through like all the streaming
services that we have which is amazon
prime shutter hulu
toby uh
i don't know we have like a bunch of
them
so i go and see like what all movies
that are available and then i'll pick
like ones that
uh to put in there and usually i have to
pick something
i pick different movies like for
for ones that we're gonna do together
than ones that i'm just gonna do because
i know you don't like the same kind of
movies as me so i usually try to pick
something that you that you'll probably
enjoy watching as well yeah okay but
it's getting harder to do that because
we've covered like so many right of the
sort of classics but
like i said we can go back and pick
stuff apart i want to do that uh i want
to do the i am legend series basically
which is all right which is
last man on earth that's modern earth oh
mega man and and i'm a legend and
they're all different but they're all
based on the same book yeah um
and
people i didn't like the will smith
third one but i want to see it again i
didn't love it either but i haven't seen
it in a while the first one with vincent
price was pretty good but for me the
ultimate is always going to be a
charlton heston [ __ ] omega man
and it's it's real relevant now
all right with the with the family and
disintegrating bio warfare
disintegrating [ __ ] society
basically antifa running around trying
to destroy the [ __ ] past and
destroying technology and and then he's
the last man on earth and he's a monster
they're both monsters just depends on
your point of view it's a good move
has a lot a lot of uh
deeper meanings to it you know
that uh when you become the last one
even though you might have been
something respectable you're now [ __ ]
the last one you're seen as a monster
by monsters
you know that we're all monsters
yeah i just i just liked it
i mean i like last month the best
because that's the most faithful to the
book but you know and vincent price
because i mean i just like the charlotte
heston one because it had a bigger scope
and it was just uh
um it had been updated for the 70s which
i just liked it you know uh i liked the
the tone of the movie he felt you know
that it felt very like isolated him
running through the city with that
[ __ ] smith and wesson mk 760 sub
machine gun with a flashlight on it and
he's looking for [ __ ] clothes to wear
and the shops and he doesn't bother
watching anything he just throws [ __ ]
off and just puts a new one on because
[ __ ] he's got a whole city full of
clothes
why do laundry
you know it's just kind of a cool thing
kind of a cool way of
cool post-apocalyptic movie you know
that's all
kind of watson says i still have mental
issues with mulholland drive ha hahaha
never seen lost highway maybe i'll go
crazy
um probably lost highway wouldn't push
you over the edge but for sure inland
empire would
[Laughter]
which i actually have it on blu-ray i've
seen it a couple times
and
lost highway is not complicated to me
mulholland drive is not complicated to
me inland empire
is um
yeah it's pretty lynchy
but
i don't know but i dig it though it's
like just the whole vibe of it it's long
it's like three hours more maybe more
than three mind bend you you know
rebooting the movie in the middle of the
movie and the characters are in the
movie and you're watching the movie the
movies watching itself all that kind of
i mean if you know a lot about david
lynch and about what his obsessions are
what his proclivities are then a lot of
times you can like figure it out because
he tends to explore
the same kinds of themes yeah um you
know in his movies that's just kind of
like like i said what his obsessions are
so if you've seen like a lot of his
stuff then i think it kind of gets
easier to like we saw the trailer for
the new cronenberg movie looks good
practical effects
yeah crimes of the future i'm excited
about lots of body horror i just saw
some [ __ ] just put up a review
of it today so they must be letting some
people see it early
um i want to go see that movie men
because i think that starts this week
i've seen a couple reviews of that going
up and like
i don't like watch the reviews obviously
but sometimes you can tell by the
[ __ ] like expressions on their
faces like on the title cards and i was
like ooh maybe this is gonna be good
khan's asked me if i've seen those lynch
movies yeah i've seen them i i can't
really watch them
they're
they're just i can watch them but i'm
just like man
the one that the one that um
kept
[ __ ] with me
what well first of all i like to race
her head okay yeah i i watched that i
love eraserhead um
i i didn't understand all of it but you
don't have to you just
trip out
um the one that got me was the dude with
the [ __ ] camera
um
that's lost highway lost highway yeah
that was weird [ __ ] i'm at your house
right now yeah and i still don't
understand that [ __ ]
i understand well lost highway and
mulholland drive are very very
thematically very similar i think
mulholland drive is a better movie
overall like i think mulholland drive is
actually his masterpiece
but lost highway is really good too but
if you've seen mulholland drive it's you
know it's similar to like lost highway
inland empire
is i really need to watch that again
i've seen it a couple times but like i
said it's kind of a commitment because
it's like really long and it's really
complex you know what i mean it's really
[ __ ] weird i always thought
um
straw dog 78 said lost highway is
probably one of lynch's most accessible
to be honest i always kind of thought
that maybe blue velvet was his most yeah
that was i forgot about that was his
most accessible because it's not really
all that it's not all metal weird yeah
and i kind of feel like maybe the first
it's my phone's ringing yeah um maybe
the first season of like twin peaks
was pretty
accessible like it's weird
but
you could kind of like you could figure
out what was going on you know i mean it
wasn't that weird yeah
it's uh the next review inland empire
yeah i kind of want to like watch that
again
and i still have
i still want to do like a mega i just
haven't had time to do it but i still
want to do like a mega episode of all
the twin peaks because i have all three
seasons like on disc like on blu-ray
like i have the big set like i bought it
for myself for a present and i still
haven't got a chance to like sit down
and watch it i've seen the first two
seasons but i just want to like watch it
all in one
you know
in one go
because i haven't seen the third one yet
but like i said it's like a long it's
long
uh yeah startup 78 says i'm currently
re-watching twin peaks the return been
five years since it premiered i know i
can't believe it's taken me this [ __ ]
long never seen twin peaks
it's good it's kind of like a weird
it's like a soap opera but
surreal you know what i mean um
yeah twin peaks the return feels more
like mulholland drive than original twin
peaks yeah i kind of feel like that's
what a lot of people said so but i want
to kind of watch all three of them just
so i like remember and maybe i might
throw
um firewalk with me in there too because
i also have that on just like the movie
like the prequel that's like the two
twin peaks prequel
well mahalo drive was originally
supposed to be a series two which amazes
me that it turned out as well as it did
that it was supposed to be a series and
they're like okay well you can't do a
series now so he's like [ __ ] i'll
just make it a movie and he just kind of
like
i think he kind of like i don't want to
say he like makes stuff up as he goes
along
but
he just works very intuitively
and somehow it comes out being like kind
of profound you know what i mean
i don't know how how he does that he's a
lot smarter than me i guess
but uh yeah so i guess we've got
wandered far afield from sam raimi's
drag me to hell but that's okay we did
talk about that movie okay how about
they want it
yeah that's what we're doing okay so
yeah so i guess we'll sign off for today
and today's tuesday so tomorrow is
wednesday which means tomorrow is our
main show and tomorrow we're going to be
talking about bonnie and clyde i gotta
check the booze you gotta check the
booze we gotta do a booze check yeah
we're gonna do the bonnie and clyde show
tomorrow yeah uh because that's my side
okay yeah i'm well versed on body cloth
that won the the poll like
overwhelmingly okay
so you know i even know the weapons that
they used so that should be a fun ass
show yeah uh so yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by and
we'll see you guys tomorrow evening bye